welcome to my office told me or a 911  operator yeah I lied I'm a full-service  fantasy professor all I need is someone  to help me clean up be my bodyguard you  know like the Kevin Costner my Whitney  Houston if it cost her its shot at the  end you trust me how much okay so tell  me about your friend the dominatrix we  were like in love fun like a friend sort  of weird codependent love it's  complicated  TIFF everyone thinks Dom work is just  about sex work it's really just  liberation from shame what brings you in  today oh you know it's actually it's not  for me it's for me I'm sorry I didn't  it's for me me it's for my husband  [Music]  not cut off what just happened in there  you're braver than you think  yep what'd you do with me that's brave  [Music]  how come you never tell me anything  because if I told you what we were gonna  do before we did it then you wouldn't do  it  [Music]  you